[Music]
what's up everybody do you miss this do
you wish you could carry us with you
wherever you go
yeah well it's all right cuz guess what
we're bringing podcasts to you and I'm
not kidding I know I was happen but
seriously we are bringing podcasts to
you so you can listen to us on the go
just go to the description box below
click on the links and there you go
also if you like what you're hearing
give us by the stars if you hate it keep
it to yourself keep on truckin and crazy
roommate news submitted by why'd you do
it too crazy a 72 year old man was
arrested after using a lawnmower to
fooling gravel at his roommates family
so he went off for a gravel pit you know
the real loser is him cuz that's gonna
[ __ ] up his blades it's probably that
old one I'll get so jealous with people
because I always had to like mow our
lawn back at home and then the people
who have more money had that good [ __ ]
dude or it would just pull by itself and
you really just have to put your hand on
it got power steering if you have one
without the motor no I might had a motor
but that you would have to push as hard
as you can over the grass but the good
[ __ ] had like 5 horsepower she was just
cuz you're weak no because it literally
said 5 horsepower in neon green and I
was stare at it in jealousy and they
would just literally just have one hand
on it and they'll just know I don't talk
to my neighbors I must have been really
stupid because every time the frickin
landscape guys came I would [ __ ] open
the window be like I wish I was out
there with you why because I [ __ ]
used to moan like my friends lawns and
stuff like that when their dad does
sounds like I want to try and I'm like
that shit's so fun and then the leaf
blower and the [ __ ] weed whacker
- it's fine dude I wouldn't
I hope my aunt or her husband my uncle I
guess he has a landscaping business and
over the summers my mom would make me go
over there and I would help out I
started a lot more business you know
that like I got my friends lawn mower
and then we just went door-to-door and
we were just like can I cut your grass
and he started giving us money and some
ladies gave us like ice cream and [ __ ]
and all kinds of random stuff we weren't
even looking for money we're just like
can I cut your grass report yeah cuz it
was so fun just cutting grass do you
think you're like oh sure we get money
too like we don't want this we rats yeah
we were just we just wanted and then
turn into a business all right so this
story takes place in Texas Texas Texas
Galveston County all right so this man
named Johnny 72 years old what that
should look like Count Dracula dude what
the [ __ ]
remember the late night horror story yes
that's a human Crypt Keeper yeah he
rises got one janitor and I'm Harry
Potter yeah this guy looks like he
[ __ ] rapes murders sells drugs has a
[ __ ] child [ __ ] labor camp like
[ __ ] he looks like he does employ he
wears people's skin for [ __ ] pleasure
and she like every sin I everything dude
where did he get that tie-dye Superman
shirt from what if he's really sweet
though I doubt it I doubt it too
I mean if he's sweet as any on his
lawnmower and throw travel on a
nine-year-old legit looks like Count
Dracula hasn't had blood in 4,000 years
that's what it looks like damn that
devil does look like a kind of guy that
would do that with his lawmen he does
man so his roommates has a nine-year-old
daughter no way could have died yeah she
got hit in the nose oh yeah can I say
something about ugly people okay
sometimes when I see people like that I
just want to attack them for no reason
is that okay
is it because you feel like they need a
bunch of wrongs I feel like they're
villains like they're wrong I don't like
the same kind of mentality as racism but
it's ugly sysm okay like I don't judge
the color of your skin I judged by how
ugly old faces well we're all ugly to
someone I don't you a [ __ ] they could
come attack me
I know self-defense that's why I take
karate he looks ok he's not an average
like Y person you know he's he's a
[ __ ] he's a Dylan I'll tell you this
I a hundred percent agree because when I
watched the Elephant Man I wasn't sad oh
he was nice I was happy that he was
stuck in that cage but why he was a nice
character I [ __ ] kingjoe you monster
Hey
sarcasm Gio what are you [ __ ] 12 you
know what blame the movies the movies
that's what made guys like this look
like villains and monsters but he is a
villain in real life he really is I'm
here to show you got the video I
wouldn't be wrong he's shooting rocks at
kids if I 300 kick him in the [ __ ]
chest I don't give a damn if he's 76
well he claims he didn't know that the
daughter was there I wonder if he's done
anything else to her oh they live
together well he said that he had kicked
them out or something I don't know here
let me show you guys a video but dude
I'd be depressed if I had a roommate
like that here you go yes hey there were
caught in a clown of gravel I'm coming
straight down the driveway and he says
if I can do it ain't just I mean it felt
like bullets but it was gravel he was
moving cuz he was shooting them rocks
like crazy oh [ __ ] here no in a chest
and others melted Angela and her 9 year
old
yeah a man on the mower claims he asked
them to leave Santa Fe jail my name's
Brittany Jeffers I work for tail - has
Tim Manning said he'd kicked Angela
Bennett out three weeks ago wait I know
the wheelchairs coming right now clay
called him names Superman he can't be
embarrassed and in there because his
voice is old and sweet he looks like
Stanley if he didn't make it
yeah I do feel kind of bad cuz he kicked
them out another coming back don't make
no sense
cuz if they're coming back in there
their dough their deposit and he was
like nah man like I'm not gonna be near
you deposit that's shot on all this area
there's a solid B dude deposits they
look like they trade pies and rum true
well you ain't getting your pot back cuz
it turned to poopy already you still
stick to your ugly people rule he's not
that bad in the video now which in the
mug shot he looked like a demon did you
learn a lesson did you learn a lesson
about your facial prejudice no because
on a good day I'd let him off the hook
on a bad day he's getting kicked in the
stomach homie BAM just like that
sometimes there's people I walk by on
the street and then I'm just like your
hair makes me want to [ __ ] sock you
in a throat dude you know who makes me
feel that way
smelly people hell that's even worse and
as smelly people makes me want to take
their face and drag it on the floor
because it is not fair that we have to
breathe that in and you know you smell
and if someone looks good or like they
take time to like just nice or whatever
I get to me I'm like bipolar when it
comes to looking like visuals right I'm
like oh thank you like I want to give
them a [ __ ] million dollars if I
could because it's like thank you for
dressing nice that was for me but if
they're [ __ ] nasty I'm like
can sack of [ __ ] wait then why don't you
always dress nice then because I'm the
observer it's about yeah no it's no I'm
saying like what about for Jess oh oh I
thought you're saying they dress when
you're a couple yeah that's real love
you fart in front of each other you let
everything just relax no it's
interesting when a really pretty person
walks by like how fast they grab your
attention it's so fascinating like he
just oh yeah do this - she was so
beautiful that he Humphrey yeah see
girls can do that huh like when another
girl walks by like wow you are just you
know I didn't tell her anything but yeah
like she was just like she just kept
grabbing me and Keith needs attention
when like we could just stare at her
forever
what was so hot about her not that she
was hot it's just like she had like this
really classic beauty about her like she
was just like a time capsule lady just
so women did they walk by you just like
it's like they walk by in slow-mo and
then little flower petals are coming out
from there yeah yeah man some of them
did those women are crazy dude there's
some really good-looking dudes - I don't
think guys walk around and then like
dandelion things fall or like I don't
think that yeah yeah what a really
good-looking guy walks by I almost like
dude don't want next to me man
he's by comparison is just not good
makes you go up that way a little boats
holes are also rare - yeah I do have a
do like catch your attention like oh
[ __ ] that's good-looking you know really
good-looking
mr. dark so brothers but I think they're
like way better looking and pictures
because I'm real after just goofy and
they look you know they're just like
junior high kids oh they don't have the
cool guy swag yeah yeah there's there's
dudes that walk in a room they take a
breath away you're talking about the
cigar so brothers in like 20 years
in the picture like the handsome man oh
you look like they are the visual
package but they don't have that you
know I mean that Italian smooth guy
[ __ ] I know I got a fat dick type of
dude gives an like a human stallion
their holiday looking like David Beckham
oh yeah he has that presence like don't
come near me
cuz you're I'm gonna look like a [ __ ]
pimple next to you yeah
you know Zen humans were animals they
are like the thoroughbreds and I'm like
the chimpanzee if you like when he walks
by you just say Mel burnt cigars and
whiskey and [ __ ] just getting wet
oh yeah Mel's good though yeah like
those things that usually smell very
good but you do sit on like swisher
Sweets and wet person when you watch
they're like what Drakkar Noir tries to
be ah yes the caramel is a claw like a
spicy cologne that's what they try to be
that's the type of man I'm talking about
you smell like [ __ ] treated leather
homey I wonder what it's like to be like
that death to be a do like that yeah
it's so easy to get girls that they
become gay
[Laughter]
[Music]